I I don't mean for this to say that no  one should ever be a vegan knowledge is  power though  but I can't apologize if it sounds like  I'm saying that because humans are not  meant to be vegan and veganism is a  privilege of the elite where you have to  be educated enough to know what your  deficiencies will be because you will  have deficiencies there's no questioning  that and you have to be wealthy enough  to afford the high quality supplements  to make up for it so if you can do that  all right well then all right high five  you're gonna be fine hopefully I think  vegetables are things that can be  enjoyed and and maybe even used  deliberately with a purpose for to a  healthy end  um and that's why I'm very warm to  vegetables eaten not not don't drink  them of course don't juice them  um but but in general I would still say  the bulk of what's coming in should be  protein and fat